si la parole est à monsieur gérard
cherpion monsieur le président la
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
vingt-six mille 600 demandeurs d'emplois
de plus en catégorie à plus de 50 4400
toutes catégories en avril depuis son
élection la politique de françois
hollande a conduit 1024251 millions 24
mille personnes et alors que le chômage
atteint un record
vous êtes dans le déni est votre
calendrier d'inaction le prouve le jour
même de la publication de ces chiffres
vous consulté les partenaires sociaux à
matignon qu'en est il ressorti
rien selon les participants si ce n'est
un conseil des ministres le 9 juin pour
peut-être intégrer en dernière minute
des mesurettes dans des projets de loi
déjà voté en première lecture nous
apprenons en tout cas que vous misez sur
les tpe et pme
pourtant vous les a sommés de nouvelles
règles tant administratives que
financières pourquoi si ce sont des
leviers de création d'emplois comme nous
le pensons et de dison chaque semaine le
fait demeure faites-vous pas confiance
c'est de confiance dont ont besoin les
chefs d'entreprises cde confiance dont
ont besoin les salariés votre méthode
est toujours la même prendre l'argent de
la poche des français pour l'injecter
massivement dans les contrats aidés
ainsi cent mille nouveaux contrats aidés
sont annoncés monsieur le premier
ministre je vous rappeler le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi dans notre pays
3 millions 794 milles en catégorie à à
n'avoir aucun travail 5 millions six
cent quarante cinq mille toutes
catégories confondues pensez vous que ce
sont cent mille contrats qui sont la
solution
bien sûr que non c'est un sparadrap que
vous a posé pour masquer une
augmentation de chiffres catastrophiques
concernant notamment le chômage des
jeunes et le suivi des seniors qui
inexorablement continuer à progresser au
lieu de gâcher l'espoir des français
vous devriez réinjecter l'argent dans
les entreprises qui sont les seuls
capables à créer les emplois durables et
de la croissance
alors monsieur le premier ministre vous
aviez dit aimer l'entreprise prouvez le
quand allez vous enfin sortir de vos
mesures pansements et proposer aux
français des mesures courageuses
mais si la parole est à monsieur
françois rebsamen ministre du travail de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
et du dialogue social
merci selon les gants et les messieurs
les députés
monsieur le député gérard cherpion
effectivement votre votre question
n'englobe pas comme l'avait fait le
député fromentin tout à l'heure les
raisons des difficultés auxquels notre
pays est confronté
cela a été fort bien rappelé par la
ministre de l'économie
cela fait dix ans un peu plus de dix ans
que nos entreprises perdent leur
compétitivité dans leurs relations avec
l'étranger cela fait plus de dix ans que
leur situation se dégrade régulièrement
et vous n'avez pas beaucoup agi puisque
la situation nous avons trouvé au niveau
économique et et que vous connaissez
c'était je voudrais vous rappeler les
trois derniers chiffes champions sont
intéressants
c'était une croissance zéro au premier
trimestre 2012 et moins 0,3 de
croissance au deuxième trimestre 2012
c'est l'héritage que vous nous avez
laissé et face à cela les faces acheta
le gouvernement agit dans une
conjoncture qui est difficile avec le
rapport louis gallois de louis gallois
nous avons commencé à rétablir les
marges des entreprises et les résultats
économiques que nous voyons en ce moment
sur le produit de cela ces entreprises
rétablisse d'abord leurs marges et vous
le savez pertinemment pour regagner des
parts de marché et le décalage est là
avec le chômage et la création d'emplois
alors pour lutter contre cela
bien sûr nous prenons des dispositions
et le gouvernement combat il crée il
crée aujourd'hui beaucoup de formations
pour les demandeurs d'emploi il utilise
les emplois aidés c'est vrai et vous
pouvez les critiquer mais quand j'ai
regardé combien vous en aviez utilisé
pendant le premier semestre 2000
vous avez consommé près de 350 mille
emplois aidés vous êtes mal venu pour
venir nous donner des leçons aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le ministre